two
guys we are here it's the leftovers
reporting from our secret location
underground impenetrable concrete
layered with lead to protect from radio
uh uh radiation and nuclear monkey pox
smallpox what is monkey coronavirus i've
seen that in the news yeah it's uh it's
popping off it's like another kind of
viral disease apparently that's like i
don't know monkey pox
sex with the monkey again or something
no i don't i have no idea what happened
i don't know how it happened but there's
a confirmed case in italy in a confirmed
case in memphis brothers think about
monkey pox dan i read about it last
night apparently it's not uh very
infectious it's kind of hard to get
infected by it so i don't think but is
it like super deadly kind of vibe uh
medium deadly
those monkeys
brutal man i mean yeah
i don't know anything about it i just
said monkey box cause you know
the government's lying to us brother
they wanna they want you to we don't
know about what vaccine they want you to
get another vaccine they're lying i'm
turning you extra gay
you're looking pretty meaty today dude
you counting your car your micros and
stuff um my my macronutrients and my
micronutrients uh yeah i mean i've been
doing that thank you for noticing yeah
yes
i mean so what's a macronutrient
macronutrients like protein
uh
uh protein carbohydrate uh and uh
fat oh those micronutrients are like the
tiny things like uh vitamins like
vitamins and [ __ ]
so why do they say keep so basically
you're just saying counting my calories
so yeah cause your trainer is always
like you counting your your macros and
i'm like whoa that's like crazy science
no not even calories well the reason for
that is because um
people want you like your trainer is
gonna want you to eat a certain amount
of protein
i mean this is like bro science a little
bit but um you need to eat a certain
amount of protein
depending on like how much muscle mass
you have lean muscle mass you have and
um the simplest way to do that is
usually instead of counting like all
your calories throughout the day you
just see that as like the main marker to
hit like a certain
uh
certain amount of protein a day what's
your calorie intake per day
um i try to stay under 2 385 calories a
day that's pretty low um yeah i i have
uh yeah i think like i don't know if
it's because of like uh doing omad one
meal a day dieting and all this other
stuff throughout my or because i'm
getting older like
i just i have a very low
caloric intake to maintain to be at a
deficit wow do you ever feel famished
like dang like no no no no no no
yeah i mean i get famous if i don't hit
3000 calories a day i get like man i
mean if you get used to it for sure i
think it's like it's definitely it's
definitely training by the way trigger
warning eating disorder if you have one
obviously you know consult a doctor and
do whatever
uh works for you yeah you're [ __ ] out
i'm just talking about what works for me
uh not as a universal rule or anything
like that
yeah count your macro i don't want
people to with eds hassan yeah wants bad
stuff to happen to black people oh my
gosh this on do you want to respond to
that i i have no response he
he got me so good dude i mean that was
pretty crazy if you think about it by
the way we're going to talk about this
on friday but it's kind of breaking news
that i haven't had a chance to dig into
but def noodles if you know him is suing
keemstar for defamation because keemstar
said he's a p word with no evidence
and
admitted to making it up which is what
makes it actually an interesting case
yes yeah oh my god yeah so that's like
that's good it's very it's very
difficult to sue someone for defamation
in america
um are
like
you have to literally prove intent you
have to prove that not only did they lie
about you you have to prove that they
did it with a malicious intent yeah
knowing that it was a lie yeah that's so
hard yeah and he might have that with
keemstar that's great i mean yeah
keemstar is just like you just point to
keemstar as a person and be like this is
malicious and then every court would be
like you're right actually well we'll
see
keemstar was sued once before for
defamation by some dj
interesting for claiming he was a like a
predator or something he actually lost
that one
because oh he did it
or no keemstar won that one oh yeah
excuse me yeah
but we'll see how it goes with it that's
probably what galvani now he's just like
i can i can defame anyone i want i'm
keemstar
and i won the court case
yeah well we have so much to get to guys
we have a big big show here today first
of all let's just start from the top we
got some really nice things on the
docket here
george bush
you know he's such a good guy such a
great president
you know george bush he's really
reformed himself into like this gentle
sweet painter oh yeah and we forget that
he is a war criminal like
he he gave uh candy to michelle obama
and ellen uh ellen hangs out with him
this is ellen's best friend
famously yeah i mean how many i mean
millions of iraqis died yeah
absolutely pointless it wasn't a
pointless war was to literally plunder
them for the vice president
but here he goes he's talking about the
ukraine or not the ukraine ukraine
and uh
well
he is a little slip up in contrast
russian elections are rigged
political opponents
are imprisoned or otherwise eliminated
from participating in the electoral
process
wait can you pause it for a second
before we get to the good juicy stuff
i just want to say that the irony of
george w bush not only saying the main
thing that everyone is focusing on uh
which we're gonna get to in a second but
the irony of him saying like oh you know
the illegal elections is how vladimir
putin came to power i'm like
[ __ ] you that's what you did
like your brother your brother's a
[ __ ] governor of florida you guys are
the brooks brothers riots and obviously
he was the original stolen uh i mean
verse four
literally yeah yeah
that that's interesting you hanging
chads butterfly ballots look it up i
mean
florida was florida was a mess like
the jewish community voted for like a
white supremacist supposedly they didn't
obviously but that should have been the
immediate inclination that like oh these
these ballots got messed up in the
reader
but no
um all right here we go one more time
now from the top
no stun lock
in contrast
russian elections are rigged
political opponents
are imprisoned or otherwise eliminated
from participating in the electoral
process
the result is an absence of checks and
balances in russia
and
the decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified and
brutal invasion of iraq i mean of
ukraine
all right anyway
i mean he literally says iraq too
dude he can't he's choking on the words
he can't even read it he's just he knows
it's so ironic the man
he has um i'm if i'm not mistaken um
this is not the first time george w bush
has actually uh talked about uh the iraq
war being
uh unjustifiable and and brutal
um
on accident
no not on accident i'm trying to find it
right now but there's no heat there's
he's reflected on he's like i think when
he's talking it to zelinski if i'm not
mistaken i was like trying to find that
earlier but maybe maybe it's not
um he's come to terms with the iraq war
being
probably not i don't know i i feel like
i've seen it
i'm trying to find it too but because of
this clip that's like all yeah this is
dominating his space but anyway look
whatever it doesn't matter he's a a
piece of [ __ ] who
uh
in this
admits
even after the flub admits iraq too
anyway oh is that what he said yeah wait
wait let me
bro don't you listen to what you said
that's so [ __ ] bad yeah wait let me
see iraq by the way this is a george w
bush like trope this is a staple like
now watch this drive another famous
george w bush moment like uh
this man is famous for this like he was
the og gaff guy right yeah well i mean
he can't even get he could barely get
through this pre-prepared speech he's so
he's just saying iraq he just back it
during his presidency every sentence was
punctuated with iraq yeah iraq i mean
that's how you justify the surveillance
state apparatus that we built in the
immediate aftermath of the patriot act
um and and you know the department of
homeland security which was created uh
in the aftermath of 9 11 like that's
it's wild to think like you think these
are like staple american institutions
it's it's
w it's a post 9 11 invention ice in and
of itself is a post-9 11 invention the
department of homeland security post 9
11
invention these are very new things that
can still be
uh destroyed abolished and should be in
mind okay here i want to catch the end
of this justified
and brutal invasion of iraq i mean of
ukraine
all right anyway
so
that's such a self-report if
if ukraine is iraq too
you're russia
yes of course
and that's going to make that very clear
to you which is why it's always funny
like i i always make this comparison i'm
always like dude russia is
straight up like russia can get dmca
copy strike by the united states for
everything that like they're doing right
now and their justifications for it
including like chemical weapon usage
potentially like wmds it's like come on
bro like you're literally vilifying
everyone that
lives there as a nazi doing exactly
exactly what the american government has
has done uh in in all of its
unjustifiable imperial endeavors america
still continues to do that they they
face no repercussions from this uh
famously for those of you who don't know
as a matter of fact
under the bush administration we passed
the legislation called um i think it's
like protecting the american service
members act or something if i'm not
mistaken i'm not getting the name right
but it's actually uh colloquially termed
dubbed uh the the invasion of the hague
act
do you know what that is no that's where
the international criminal court is
right
and the the invasion of the hague act if
you look this up invasion of hate yeah
invasion of the hague act okay the hate
being also known as the american service
members protection act okay
um
is is known informally as the invasion
of the hague act means that
uh federal state and local governments
and agencies including courts and law
enforcement agencies internationally
okay
cannot assist the international criminal
court for example it prohibits the
extraction of any person from the united
states to the icc it also prohibits the
transfer of classified national security
information to law enforcement
information to the icc the international
criminal court
um the act also prohibits use u.s
military aid to countries that are party
to the icc
i said the bomb this bill was signed
into law by president trump the
international criminal court like where
war criminals are tried yeah this is
like
the act is basically we will invade we
will invade your country we'll invade
the hague
uh if you extract any kind of if you
if you try to prosecute an american
diplomat an american military member
anyone we will invade you we will invade
your country
we haven't really held that but that
i don't think that we've
it's just giving you the cause to go in
there and do it because i'm sure that
the diplomats yeah get tried you think
that
american democrats
does that never happen no of course not
dude we don't even try our own war
criminals in in our like military uh
trials even after they're outed um
the the
the famous navy seal uh example where
like his own [ __ ] platoon right outed
him and and they would literally tweak
his they would tweak his scope on his
rifle so he stopped killing young girls
right which he was doing for fun he like
stabbed a a
a prisoner of war that was 16 years old
that was handcuffed on camera and like
posed with photos with him and then
donald trump pardoned him he like
he he interfered with the investigation
at first and then like literally
pardoned him so he could get his [ __ ]
medals back maybe uh maybe john wayne
gacy is next up to be pardoned that's i
mean who knows
it's just the the reality is
we are the imperial
dominant hegemonic power we are the
number one villains on the planet it's
just the truth and people get super
butthurt when they look at like oh well
what about russia it's like yeah russia
is bad russia is bad for invading
ukraine they are engaging in
unjustifiable acts of violence in
ukraine i totally understand that and
the reason why i always bring it back to
america is not to deflect the attention
away from russia but it's because i'm
american
okay i'm an american citizen whether you
like it or not and i am going to
criticize my government that's what i'm
able to do so if you get [ __ ] butt
hurt or if you get upset well you suck
me from the back okay sorry like that's
what a being an american is right i
thought that that's why these uh you
know soldiers were going to afghanistan
and dying for our freedoms brother and
not to protect poppy fields before they
get shot uh in the dick
while protecting a poppy field
right right no
yeah
anyway it's just it's
it's it's deeply frustrating like i want
to make jokes about this i make jokes
about everything about like all this
dark [ __ ] but uh i don't know the the
millions of unaddressed uh innocent
unexamined innocent deaths
is is so frustrating every single one of
these bush uh administration officials
including all those [ __ ] [ __ ]
that are on msnbc every night saying oh
we're never trump republicans like we're
actually you know moderate republicans
like all those [ __ ] should be
[ __ ] tried okay in a in a just world
they would all go to prison it would be
under the prison
every single one of them but they're not
they own the prison yeah
they not they're not they never will be
obama [ __ ] up by not uh even
prosecuting the prior administration for
for you know torture which we did
remember state sanctioned torture
beyond what like norway considered to be
i mean we foreign to we haven't even
locked up hillary clinton so i don't
even know how you can't break the seal
yeah
yeah lock her up yeah you break the seal
it's all [ __ ] it's like hillary
clinton is almost single-handedly
responsible for the evisceration of
libya like the the reason why there's
open slave markets in libya now almost
single-handedly responsible that was
another nato action by the way nato so
great love nato uh bombed the [ __ ] out
of [ __ ] libya that was cool
they had it coming
yeah i'm just chilling in cedar rapids
you don't hate it dude
remember what pete remember what pete
davidson's he's her hero he uh
yeah i i think that's so wet he has a
tattoo that's
a red flag dude um here is uh you know
again just some short clips at the top
of the show to break the seal here
oh here's yeah i always like to look at
this pete davidson
america's heartthrob
with look i think he's a funny dude but
that's the that's such an insane thing
like that is such an absolute and it
says uh what's the caption my hero
hillary
does a uh wanted to get hillary clinton
a christmas gift so i got a tattoo of my
hero thanks for being such a badass and
one of the how's that
universe okay that's so egotistical the
gift for her is a tattoo for you this is
like okay homer simpson
ariana grande there is literally no just
there there's nothing
everything is broken dude okay that
bothers you more than the than the kim
kardashian thing 100
that's the love ariana grande
i love you yeah she's married if you're
watching if you're watching it's cool
all right here's joe here's joey
uh with a banger
he's talking about
dude i don't even know what news sources
joe rogan is consuming to think this
[ __ ] but he is you guys have to
understand
he's concerned he's consuming really
fringe weird
uh a right-wing
news headlines and regurgitating it i
mean this is like infowars [ __ ] here
listen to this i want to find out what
this is but i read something briefly and
i didn't get into the article but they
were saying that they were trying to
pass a bill that would outlaw you
growing your own food in australia oh my
god oh my god it was a part of australia
i think it was new south wales
someone's trying to pass a law that
won't allow you to grow your own food oh
my god and they were saying well you
could grow your own food and what if the
disease was from your food it affects
the population i love that
again
he's such a he's so funny like what a
legend in the comedy right now dude i
love
i love joe rogan's comedy actually i
didn't realize but he's a stool [ __ ]
no that is like i was supposed to say
that's a whole straight stool [ __ ]
behavior right there
yeah but that the best part is he gets
so deep into this bit you know making
fun of this like oh look at these
liberal woke morons and then it's just
[ __ ] wrong you got a big payoff at
the
what their justification was but i'm
pretty sure it had to do with like
agricultural contamination or you know
like i mean you could justify it if
you're a real piece of [ __ ] you could
say well you know most pandemics have
come from agriculture animal agriculture
we can't have unchecked pig ownership
that's not fair we can you be growing
vegetables what have your vegetables
ever got in them and
diseases
[ __ ] creeps man
yeah
super creepy yeah uh this is this is
gonna be a really funny turning point
for him uh coming up but dude he his
cognitive dissonance is just through the
[ __ ] roof dude he's so happy he's
like he's in the pocket right now he's
like right right right right i'm owning
the entire continent of oxford
right
a bunch of liberal [ __ ] watching yeah
these [ __ ] creeps they they got a
good grip on people during the pandemic
they locked it right down nostril and
then you know what we're going to stop
these [ __ ] from growing their
own food because that's how you [ __ ]
smoke out an anti-vaxxer
make you can't even grow their go to the
grocery store only only anti-vaxxers
grow tomatoes
as you know a gardening is a is a
right wing exclusive right win wing
activity you can't grow your food no
dependent take that shot [ __ ]
you find me dude i love you are now
dependent i love that he's his like
first of all obviously there has to be
agricultural uh rules joe should know
this i i mean he basically admits as to
why there are certain regulations
on like what the pesticides you can use
especially when you're [ __ ] australia
like when you're a gigantic island
okay
there that's the same reason why there
are pl there's like a lot of uh you know
livestock rules as well you can't like
bring your pets into australia or if you
do they have to be like you can't do
that in any country yeah you have to
undergo literally every country super
strict quarantine but australia is like
incredibly strict more strict than other
places for that reason um he recognizes
that like even if this was true there
could be a good reason for it but he
says it in like a mocking way or he's
like who's so stupid well he he's being
like you can't even plant a tomato in
your backyard anymore yeah that's a
god-given right here
passes bill
i mean i know what to look for i'm just
it's not nothing's coming up uh the
closest thing i could find was something
like this i don't that's not who food no
it's nothing it's not
it's such a niche misinformation that
they can't even find it on google
i'm gonna give that's impressive i'm
gonna give [ __ ] props to jamie i
think like it's kind of like that cheeto
holding the door before the [ __ ] cops
like bust in meme you know what i mean
like the cheeto deadlock
but like jamie is literally that [ __ ]
little cheeto piece like stopping
just incredible amounts of
misinformation from flowing directly
into like 90 million [ __ ] people well
he doesn't believe him he double checks
him on his face in australia i know but
this is close new zealand is like right
around the corner could have
um there's god it's got to be a real
thing it's gotta be too good to not be
it's it's obviously um
uh outlaw growing food in australia and
nothing not a single thing comes up
dude that's why he's short you know okay
i'm being a little parasocial here but
like you know he's he seems a little bit
short with joe over here he's like
there's it's not real joe
well you know he's probably sitting
there as joe rogan googles for 10
minutes trying to prove his where do you
think he gets this niche miss info it
must be facebook you
percent like homies consuming weird
facebook content i mean that should
concern everybody bro he has he has like
weird homies that are sending them this
stuff no i mean who are the [ __ ]
speed dial it's not i think this is not
even alex jones
i think this is just like all of the
all of the people that he has uh
surrounded himself with they're all yes
men they're all terrified of him um and
they probably like
you know go further and further into
like that conspiracy hole to like
satiate his thirst for and his hunger
for for more misinformation yeah more
approval more you know yeah so he um
[Music]
outlaw growing food in australia and
nothing not a single thing comes up
hold on this guy's having a good time
yeah his gash was a false
thing
growing their own food they wanted they
want us watch watch your hotel jesus oh
pendant
yeah i can't find it either damn it dude
what's up hotep jesus what's going on
you're just gonna it might be fake
but
even if it's fake right like the fake is
usually the warning that's a good
yeah that that's really insightful i
love that i love that he's like trying
to save it okay hotep jesus is [ __ ]
fire okay because i watched a bunch of
the clips from this uh broadcast first
of all he's insane like literally insane
uh surprised that like joe rogan has had
him on multiple times on his broadcast
holy [ __ ] um
but
uh he
i love him because he's he's very unique
in the way that he presents
misinformation normally what you would
say in a situation like that if you've
gotten owned by miss info is like well
isn't it crazy that like it could be
real like not examining why you thought
that but instead being like well that's
so crazy things have gotten now he just
straight up says nah fake news is
actually real news but it's a warning
it's awesome man yeah by the way we were
working on this uh
uh war crime you remember this old psa
where'd you find this weed pipe i
learned it from you dad yeah who's right
of course uh learned it from george
fisher putin is our guy i mean he is our
guy originally he's a kleptocratic uh
oligarch uh and he is a he is very much
like the singular force of american
western plunder in the aftermath of the
ussr's collapse right like
these are
like we didn't like him that much but
the people that we put in positions of
power put him in positions of power um
because you know they thought that he
would be the authoritarian strongman
that will continue collaborating with
the western world
and uh ensure that and ensure that
russia prospers but alongside
uh american boundaries george w bush
ironically why are they wearing the
exact same suit is that real or that's a
photoshop
wait why are they still wearing this
thing too
it's not the exact same bro they look
[ __ ] identical
i thought someone like photoshopped his
head on george bush no no no look at
these besties dude yeah
yeah there's so much in common to be
honest i mean they both are billionaires
from well trump putin might be a
trillionaire at this point
[Music]
from oil they love oil
and they love invading
and killing innocent people
besties they should be holding hands
skipping and they love maintaining a
tight grip on a group of oligarchs that
uh
functionally control the entire
government um in america there's it's
like distributed
uh to more oligarchs and uh the
government has less power and russia the
government has more power
but le the oligarchs have less control
because it's just like single it's
almost uh singularly dealt with by um
or controlled by vladimir putin in his
interest isn't it rumored to be that
vladimir putin's the richest person in
the world you say
google search said 70 billion i've heard
that he's the richest person in the
world all that speculation is based on
him having like secretly looted the
country and having yeah sure accounts
yeah yeah
what's publicly known is a lot less than
that but it's pretty hard to it's pretty
hard to map it out i mean he just has
you know he he gives like his daughter's
piano instructor like [ __ ] 10 billion
in an offshore account you know what i
mean it's stuff like that how are we
gonna track that it's very very
difficult yeah some websites say 200
billion
yeah
good for him man he earned it yeah he's
just working hard hard he works probably
everyone else by the way a fun fact but
uh uh part of the reason obviously like
the the lion's share of responsibility
falls on russia uh for invading ukraine
but part of the reason why these
conversations even began including in
georgia in 2008 and in ukraine in 2008
is because george w bush famously on his
way out
went against every single analyst that
told him don't do this and said we
should bring in georgia and ukraine into
nato we should do that and every every
analyst internally was like do not say
that
that is a red line you are going to you
are going to cause a fuckload of
commotion you are going to if if nato
encroaches on the russian border this
much
russia will retaliate everyone told them
not to do that and they knew full well
that
uh in order to in order for a country to
join nato they have to get
unanimous consent every single country
has to vote yes right for nato
membership every single pre-existing
nato countries vote yes germany and
france were never going to vote yes and
yet
um you know bush was like no i'm going
to do that on his way out literally i
was like interesting we should start
those conversations
well let's move it on
to our good friend xqc
twitch streamer i think this is a good
conversation for us to have together
simply because
long ago
not that long ago we had a phone call
with xqc and who else was on that call
train wreck train wrecks and xcc were
both on the call yes about gambling on
twitch and uh since then he he obviously
uh defended the position then but he
even issued an apology here it is just
to tell you guys kind of where we are so
this is uh you know from july
of last year xqc apologizes and says he
wish he could take back the gambling
like what more can i do what we're gonna
do you you shouldn't yell on stream you
shouldn't do it we've known this i said
it don't don't do it i'm sorry for doing
it
i i i i i i'm genuinely sorry that i
gave it on stream okay i wouldn't think
it back i can't i'm trying to move on
okay all i'm trying to do now is at
least the people that are gonna be
called out next and i'm not lumped with
some of the things that they do that i
didn't do can you at least guys give me
that ali is giving the
the benefit of of not looking like the
other cocklords can we can i actu at
least have this if i'm gonna get [ __ ] on
by everybody on the internet can i at
least have the very bottom of the barrel
of not lumping me in with everybody
that's all i asked for
okay well i would say that you have now
my friend
reached the bottom of the barrel
because he's back
uh
he is back
uh with a huge partnership with steak
the of course famous shed in uh
curacao
curacao shout out to the the infamous
billion dollar shed yeah and uh he's
back doing gambling streams sponsored by
steak i can only imagine god how much he
getting paid i mean if if aiden ross was
getting two million a month xqc is like
way bigger so
yeah
um i don't know i don't know how much
he's getting paid i'm not even going to
speculate on it i don't care about that
i don't care about like well unless
there's unless there's like actual
legitimate proof i don't care about like
the the game get the gambling uh
potentially being rigged right here's
the hut
religiously
this this is stakes headquarters that we
found out and curious how this is where
this huge billion-dollar corporation is
run from
yeah here he is gambling not not
suspicious not suspicious no it's
totally above no it's normal it says you
says you
um
everybody threw us all on the bus
when when
when the chips were down
everybody turned on us it was a bunch of
[ __ ] but when some streamers and some
the ones oh guys um i'm i'm going to get
bro i'm doing my gambler oh oh all the
con all the comments
everybody flips like
oh dude if it was that much money yeah
you know i would do it too i i respected
this guy
like people were selectively
uh choosing and picking it who they back
up
when
if if you're if your old motive and
whatever is behind morals and ethics
you can't pick and choose it's black out
white white or wrong and i got [ __ ]
mauled i see people [ __ ] being uh oh
we're gonna pick this and choose that
and you know what did it i think there i
was like dude i love i love gamba i like
amber i'm i'm just gonna gamble in a
story
literally i will just i mean yeah he's i
haven't seen really people doing that
we're like picking and choosing i mean
no there is no there is no like oh man
he got like yeah no i respect that he
like got the [ __ ] million dollar bag
there like look here here's a couple
different things right
my main position for since day one is
that first of all i don't do these kinds
of sponsorships i think that they are
abhorrent uh i think that they're awful
uh unfortunately though a steak and all
these other like cryptocurrency uh
initiatives and gambling in general
fanduel draftkings all of them are are
very popular and have basically
reached legitimization uh because they
generate so much revenue and they can
like buy their way into some kind of
legitimacy um so i don't even think
twitch as a platform is going to combat
it or deal with it but ultimately the
individual responsibility of a content
creator is is what i care about in this
particular instance like dude
xqc has a lot of fans who love him they
look up to him they literally change
their dialect
to sound more like him because they
watch him so much a lot of those dudes
are young they're 100 seeing him gamble
and they're also getting into gamble and
it's super easy to
actually join and gamble it's hard to
get get money out it's much harder to
get money out but it's really easy to
put money in i don't think you can get
money out i mean really if i'm being
honest that's not you can you can
let me tell you something the what's so
shady about steak
is that it's a crypto only casino okay
that means that you don't have to put in
your credit card there's no verification
process there's literally no due
diligence
in fact we had love who
i guess he just turned 21 but it doesn't
really matter
love are you there
yes i am
so here let's play this video so we had
love
uh sign up make an account and deposit
money we wanted to see how hard it was
before i i said you know what i don't
want to call xqc out
before i do this myself
so we had love here he is signing up
i'll show you how so love name lovebot
um
okay that's it verification
so so the name that you put in
is fake info
yes last name uh fake info
there's this okay like
like i would say back when casinos and
gambling was legal in america
there were at least like regulations and
they had a whole department
dedicated to verifying credit card
information
verifying that people like you had to
send in a picture of your id before you
could even play so watch where this goes
fake info
residence fake info
uh
okay
that's it
so now basically
we're here signed up on the casino
and then
here i'm just proving that it's the same
account because it takes it takes a
while for the phones to come in
so you're linking your crypto wallet
yeah and there the uh since i was i
think it's illegal in sweden so i just
vpn out of sweden
there no problem everyone i tried
i tried canada and that didn't work
either i switched to romania
shout out uh cobra tate
yeah
the romanian authorities are too busy
with him right now
so they can't they can't deal with the
crypto gambling okay so wait now you're
connected to romania on a vpn
right
and then that's right you what what you
put in 40 bucks how much was that
ethereum or 14 of
14.005
bitcoin ish okay and then you just got
you got right at it with razer sharks
that's under 60 dude dude that's the
112.
that's a speed run
that's that's it that's congratulations
down four three two one why you didn't
win a single spin
hey dude congratulations to 112 baby
that's the 112. he did it awesome the
mad lad
and you know well i i should tell you
too
that most the kids i'll tell you what
i'll tell you when they do verify your
id when you're trying to take money out
yes then all of a sudden oh you know
exactly who you are how old are you
where you live because if you're playing
with a vpn which probably a lot of
people are expecting to become a
millionaire or something you will never
get that money out
i don't know i don't know if it's like i
don't know if you can't get that money
out if you're playing if you are a 17
year old kid playing in california
you are gonna have to [ __ ] you i don't
think you'll ever get your money out
part of their business it's part of
their business i actually i actually
literally i can't speak on that part
because like people know what they do
i'll tell you exactly what they do they
just they so let's say you win a million
dollar jackpot
then what they'll do is say you know
what you're playing illegally we're just
going to return your original deposit
and call it a day that's what they do
you know what i want to add a thing that
wasn't very clear in that video there
i was actually able to deposit money
without using a vpn and then when i went
to gamble it in sweden uh they denied me
to gamble
so essentially the money was locked
there until i could
like
that's not that's that's sick that's a
good that's that's this seems like a
good business they don't check the geo
location on the deposit they'll take
money from anywhere i wonder why well
technically because it's not illegal to
like put your cryptocurrency into a
website in sweden but it's illegal to
gamble with it right so obviously that's
the reason we should try where i want to
love i'd be interested to see if we put
in like 10 bucks or whatever and then
try to withdraw it how easy is it
i know for a fact withdrawals are very
difficult especially with like super
large quantities of money if you want to
ever like take it out um
like it just
it becomes more of a chore especially if
you want to like cash it out i don't
think you can even do that i mean you
need to like switch it over to a crypto
wallet well stakes their marketing
budgets insane i mean they're basically
taking over drake's whole social process
yeah uh the knelt boys these are the new
sugar daddies of us unscrupulous
influencers basically
here's my thing okay
as content creators as twitch dreamers
we are incredibly fortunate okay we when
at a time when like a lot of people were
suffering financially a lot of people
were unable to get work
we were able to make more money than we
ever did before
yeah and i would say the same for a lot
of hollywood celebrities as well they
kept doing they kept working throughout
the pandemic or drake you know what i
mean you already are like a
multi-millionaire you're about to have
like a billion dollars why are you still
like
how much money do you need to make off
of like getting other people to gamble
in your community in your fan base that
that you know it's it's still
justifiable despite having just by being
like a 100 millionaire you know what i
mean that's it's wild i don't understand
it that's why i didn't i never
understood like the crypto rug pulls
either which this is uh reminiscent of
this is similar to but somehow i would
go so far as to say that it's even worse
than crypto workflows because this is a
lifelong addiction that you are right
that you are basically subjecting people
to
um
it's the most
addiction they say yeah it's the most
the
suicidal
suicidal edition i don't know if it's
the deadliest but that's what they i
mean that's like i think that's like a
trope about it it's like you don't need
this money you don't i like i'm not
asking people to like uh not take
sponsorship from like shitty companies
or whatever that like you know everyone
else is taking sponsorship money from
but but this is definitely like this is
definitely where i draw the line
um especially because one you already
have a lot of money two your your uh you
know this filthy addiction is what you
are basically promoting to your audience
and three
um
here's how this works
here's how uh these these massive
casinos uh uh operate okay if you don't
know
they are trying to cast as wide a net as
possible because they know that some
people are going to gamble for free for
the first time they even give you money
for your first trial
you know the first hit is always free
like [ __ ] you know cocaine dealers
um
knowing full well knowing full well that
there is going to be a whale
in that large literally their business
yeah that's their business model they
look for whales what are whales look at
lifetime earnings exactly lifelong
gambling addicts and they and they milk
them dry they ruin their life without
any because that's their whole business
model right yeah here this is from stop
predatorygambling.com
gambling is the deadliest addiction uh
below is one of the best analysis
explaining why gambling addiction has
the highest rate of unaliving of any
addiction the psychological effects of
problems gambling can be extremely
harmful and the feelings of despair that
come with gambling away one's money is
so toxic
um
so
the thing about gambling is that
you know
like back back when it's the thing is
that this is so it's unregulated
so i'm just thinking there was a time
briefly i remember when i was young
where gambling and poker rooms were
allowed and you could write them and say
hey i have an addiction you need to ban
my ip and all my accounts and my id yeah
and they will never let you open an
account again and they can actually
enforce that
because
they have your id and you need to show
your id to play these places
have no such obligation and they make no
effort to have services like that where
they're actually you know giving people
an out
to save their lives
uh
you can never if you get truly addicted
to gambling which you're very
susceptible to at a young age especially
horrible for a young developing mind
they will
suck you dry until you're dead basically
yeah and there are already so many
anecdotes from his community i don't
know if they're like being honest or not
but there's plenty of people in his in
his actual subreddit like posting their
own personal experiences with gambling
and how they started right and how much
money they lost so far
and
look ultimately this is what i always
say these companies want to make money
right
if they weren't getting a return on
their investment when they're dropping
two million into someone's bank account
every month just doing this kind of
sponsorship if they weren't getting more
than two million they wouldn't drop two
million it's not like they're you know
paying extra however much amount of
money that they're paying because they
love losing money or they're just like
big [ __ ] juicers they're big juicer
fans like no they're doing it because
they know that it when xg is slot
gambling with 100 000 kids watching okay
with adults as well especially
but like 100 000 fans watching out of
that group of people a certain
percentage of those guys are going to
convert to what is known as whales yeah
lifelong gambling addicts okay and that
number is going to be significant enough
that however much however many millions
that he will get paid for this is going
to be
nothing in comparison to the return and
you can see that with even like a much
smaller streamer good friend of mine
yasuo who once showed his earnings like
or not earnings but
the lifelong gambling
not lifelong lifetime total gamble yeah
life lifetime total gamble for using his
code specifically that part is actually
really
really awful too uh they track who your
biggest uh who your biggest losers are
that use your code yeah usually when
they have a when they have a sponsorship
code um
and then they give you a percentage of
them yeah they give you they you buy
into your audience losing money
basically yeah and um and he was showing
that and he had like 26 million total
gamble you know what i mean like and
he's not that big he's like 5 000 people
watch him uh when he's gambling and he
already had like 26 million total
gambled so it's like three percent of
that was uh the the monthly yeah damn
that's nuts
yes so i mean
i
that's so crazy oh my god
it's just so bad you guys and it like
if this was a regulated gambling like
place that had
re respectable laws and gambling
addiction support it wouldn't be as bad
okay because xqc and all these guys try
to make this moral argument about like
uh you've done this and they've done
this and it's not the same and say this
is an unregulated website that
everybody's promoting they have no
[ __ ] issue
taking money from kids
it's it's so [ __ ] yeah no for the
record by the way i was really
disappointed to see him go back i want
to point out what like my personal
boundaries are in this like i think that
is a multiplier that makes it
significantly worse but i still
personally think it's bad across the
board because i think that like uh even
with all of the rules and regulations
put in place
vegas is still a multi-billion dollar uh
you know is
gambling is a multi-billion dollar
industry across the board even with the
physical
hurdle that you need to overcome by
straight up flying into vegas even with
all of the free comp stuff that they
give you if you go and gamble
it's still it's still making a shitload
of money because people go and they love
gambling and they love losing millions
of dollars and they keep it afloat it's
it's an industry i have no problem with
what goes on in vegas no i like gambling
i i personally like gambling i do i i
sometimes go to vegas and i lose money
any vice you know i mean yeah you can
take it too far but the problem is you
don't give 12 you don't give like 15
year olds alcohol and then
when their mom says yo you got to stop
giving my kid alcohol you say [ __ ] you
you come i just i just would not
i like gambling personally uh and i do
it from time to time
but you're exactly correct i would not
like urge other people to go do it and
be like look how sick this is
even if you say don't gamble they're
still gonna gamble yeah that's your
dumbest thing
now these guys think it justified to be
like we say don't gamble you will lose
money that's train wreck's thing he goes
don't gamble you will lose money it will
ruin your life it's horrible all right
guys here's my code on the top of the
screen train wreck he doesn't he doesn't
wanna vote anymore uh he used to do it
but he does i think he hid the code now
but um i don't think he needs it anymore
because they just pay him so much but
the thing is yeah demonstrably um the
money the money has not run out on on
the stake side because you are not
you're not a loss leader for them you're
not even
you know you're you're
giving them an appropriate return on
investment to the tune of millions of
dollars that your fan base is losing i
get
i get that there's like like these guys
these streamers are making millions and
millions of millions of dollars every
month
potentially tens 20 million dollars a
year
just in sponsorship money from stake
that's a huge that's life-changing money
obviously
but xqc is and train wreck these are
huge streamers i mean these guys have
huge opportunities they're already
making a ton of money i remember last
year xqc was the top earner
on the switch i mean he still is he's
the top he is the he has been the number
one content creator on this platform for
two years three years now and he will
probably continue to be that he's a he's
perfectly built for streaming um he has
cultivated an awesome community of
people who love him okay i have no
problem with that i like xqc you know
he's stayed at my house i i i do care
about him personally also getting
addicted to gambling because it's very
clear that he has a problem he talked
with pokeman about how he lost like 1.8
million dollars in the course of like a
couple days uh gambling because he's and
he's addicted he has family members he's
that he's lost immediate family members
he's lost to this addiction um
and and it is it is also sad to see from
that front as well but that still
doesn't excuse his behavior no not at
all what you're seeing when he's
debating and i i'm someone who's like
dealt with addiction sorry for cutting
you off overnight but like this is
something that's very personal to me
because i have uh issues with addiction
as well and it's a it's a lifelong
struggle when you are when you are an
addict okay you have to constantly work
against that
um that's why i think it's like
additionally terrifying to get people
into that it's really really terrible as
someone who struggled with it um
and and when you're addicted internally
you have a
you have a constant debate going on with
your consciousness part of you knows
it's wrong and you're like i shouldn't
gamble anymore i shouldn't gamble it's
like really bad for me i think like
nothing feels good anymore
i'm always chasing that high that
dopamine that i get
from the anticipation of the reveal not
the actual wins or loses itself by the
way it's the like there's studies
conducted on this they look at your
brain activity it spikes right before
the reveal that's what you're going for
so it doesn't matter if you're winning
or losing you're still going for that
dopamine rush
um
and and
you're constantly aware that like this
is a bad thing it makes you feel like
[ __ ] and you're doing it but you're
debating internally your addiction is
like winning out and debating the other
parts of your consciousness basically to
say no no it's fine like you you want a
lot you know you're going to keep
winning actually or just one more just
one more cigarette just one more drink
like it'll be okay um
and and
that is basically what he's doing now
with a hundred thousand people he's like
both he's done these uh he's had these
arguments within himself
so much and all you see when he's
deflecting and defending his addiction
is basically what an addict does when
they're when they're refusing to
engage and refusing to like try to get
better i think it's it's so unhealthy
what's going on because yeah he's
playing out his addiction in front of a
huge audience
and in a way i feel like
they're and they're gonna enable him i
mean a lot of people are angry he's gone
back but obviously his core supporters
are gonna support him no matter what
and i think they're going to enable
this really horrific if what he's saying
is true that he's just gambling the
whole time he's not streaming and he
lost yeah no i believe in the end i
believe it then then it seems like he's
lo he's lost a lot of money and he's
just kind of this might be a rock bottom
moment where he's taking the
sponsorships because he's losing so much
money i think on that side that he
justify it to himself i think that's
exactly you're right exactly right i
think it's more like i'm already losing
so much money while i'm gambling like i
might as well recoup those losses and
take the sponsorship or i'm gonna be
broke and the second thing is like look
this dude is a streaming machine okay
and gambling is super easy it's super
easy content you have a built-in
audience there's a drama associated with
it you're literally like you're just
like going after your addiction by just
like clicking a button so that's like
constantly reinforcing that part of your
brain as well it is a powder keg for
something like xqc because he's getting
the worst kind of reinforcement in the
form of like additional numbers watching
him he's got a hundred thousand people
watching when he's playing when he's
gambling but he has way less people like
60 to 80 000 when he is not gambling you
know what i mean so
that makes it even worse for someone
like xcc who just like cares about his
community who cares about streaming who
cares about making good content right
because he's like well i'm making good
content people are watching
um and and getting a sponsorship like
that
is again
the the the icing on the cake for
someone who is addicted because now you
are like you said recouping your losses
basically
but yeah i mean
yeah but oh god he's just it's so bad
it's just such a vicious cycle now he's
caught in with his fans the gang
it's so bad man
but yeah i think it's super sad super
disappointing to see him come back
especially after making that apology and
begging people please don't let me in
with the worst of a it's like okay dude
whatever that was ten months ago he's
back gambling yeah he says uh i mean he
he posted in his community he said i
don't give a [ __ ] like i i've changed my
mind like on gambling i was wrong to
have apologized like i think gambling is
fire yeah gambling rules did more
gambling in the world yeah so there you
have it
sad man
sad
and he just he moved back to canada
explicitly to
take up his uh gambling career right i
mean i don't know i don't know why he i
i i've always had them a bunch of times
in the past like month or so we haven't
really talked that much uh for a couple
months so i i don't know what is like
personal well love you know that right
did he say that he was moving back to
ken i know he you can
gamble legally on this website i mean
that's why that's why people go yes i
mean that's why train with canada like
so that is definitely a motivator but i
don't know if that's like the main
reason
uh well there you have it what do you
guys think uh actually i'm looking up in
the chat
a lot of people saying they appreciate
uh the um sort of empathy that you're
expressing because um
yeah i mean you know a lot of people
deal with addiction and
the
framing of uh what he's doing rather
than oh he's just a dick and uh you know
he's a hypocrite or whatever it's like
that
well all that is true all that is true
but that's what uh addiction turns you
into that's why when you get addicted to
things you lose friends and family yeah
is because you become
a ghost of your former self and a slave
to your addiction and you do stuff like
he's doing now that makes you look like
a [ __ ] idiot
because
you have to feed the demon dude yeah and
um
like this doesn't mean that uh this
absolves them of like the wrong doing
right for the record because like
here's the thing xqc has millions and
millions of dollars doesn't spend it on
anything you know what i mean
like he just streams all the time and i
and i i get that i understand that i'm
the same way i love streaming that's
what i love to do i don't really care
about like uh you know
making investments or whatever i just
love streaming and that's what i care
about
um
so
when he uh you know when he's like
losing all this money
uh when he's losing all his money he has
a lot longer of a runway
to continue gambling that his fan base
doesn't so his addiction can be like
super public he can deal with it
personally but if he recognizes that
like that addiction is crippling and to
a certain degree he does i think and he
definitely like changes his conduct he
uh accordingly because he doesn't want
his community to be a certain way then
you should recognize that like putting
that on putting that demon on others
within your community of people who love
you
is is awful straight up
yeah that's a really good point about
the runway yeah um
but in a sense he
he's really kind of throwing his fans
uh
under the bus in a way by going back and
as part of the addiction because he i
mean
yeah dude it's it's bad it's bad news
uh
uh
yeah
so hassan you don't think that twitch
will ever take action on this like
they're they're completely cool with
without playing on i mean i already
haven't why how would they do that do
you have gotcha games first of all
regulating that is really difficult
because you have raid apparently or like
all these like pay-to-win games mobile
games they're all little crates you have
cs go crates you have loot boxes
um
the governments that have actually like
some governments have taken action
against all of that which i think is a
good thing um but ultimately
if
a particular business can reach a level
of like revenue they can basically buy
legitimacy they can lobby the government
to ensure that regulation doesn't happen
or regulation that benefits them only
happens and and that's kind of what's
going on right now
uh wild to me that you know you can get
banned for wearing a bikini on stream in
like two seconds but you can get i got
band for seeing cracker probably seven
days like it's
it's wild yeah i mean it's it's
ruthlessly inconsistent yeah um and yes
obviously like people these a lot of
these people who love gambling or defend
gambling are the same people that
actually ironically are like super
anti-hot tub streaming
right right yeah yeah they hate that
well
what by the way you said you having a
you had an addiction what what was that
about i mean i've i've struggled with
i've talked about this openly i've
struggled with uh alcohol oh really yeah
i've struggled with alcohol addiction um
really and i used to smoke cigarettes
too both of those are terrible wait when
were you uh how long ago were you
drinking
i mean i still drink now every now and
then casually i can do it but i went
cold turkey and i had a really
incredible support group um that that
basically uh helped me
uh
go
acquit and stop drinking for a very long
time i didn't know that yeah like
i was just a binge drinker a blackout
yeah i know i was never like uh
i don't like talking about too much
because like then people will literally
use that against me in a very weird way
but it's good to be vulnerable
yeah sometimes um but yeah i've talked
about it before so it's whatever but
yeah i uh
i had alcohol problems and cigarettes
especially as well like it was
cigarettes was probably worse than
alcohol
because alcohol it was over a longer
period of time but cigarettes it was
like
it's impossible once you [ __ ] once
you pop you
actually can't stop
like straight up well if you're actually
addicted to alcohol that's one of the
worst uh drugs to give up
people straight up die from from
stopping drinking alcohol uh yeah
i had an intervention one of my closest
friends uh you got an intervention one
of my closest friends was like you this
is you know
so you were getting blackout drunk every
night i would get blackout drunk a lot
yeah wow yeah um
and um
it was i mean it's horrible you don't
you hate yourself it's not good for your
mental health it's not good for those
around you you've already mentioned it
it's just it's an awful thing
um
and uh it's very difficult very
difficult to to combat it it's very
difficult to deal with and it's
something that i have to always pay
attention to for the rest of my life
that's just the reality um i can
thankfully uh i can thankfully still
every now and then
i have like one drink but i notice
myself i know i i'm constantly
uh observing my own
uh my own brain basically where
i drink one time i won't drink for like
a year
and i drink one time at a party because
it's like a celebration you know and
you're like come on all right i'll have
one drink [ __ ] because everyone's like
peer pressuring you come on drink
and i'll have one drink and then
immediately the next day i go out i have
another drink i just went from not
drinking for a year to drinking two days
in a row and the second time i drink i
drink more than i did the first time
right and i don't let it ever get to
like a blackout but as soon as i notice
that i'm like i'm cutting it out no more
like and i just go cold turkey
um and it's just um
you know it's what i've been doing for a
long time it's been fine is it her
drinking in your family
um
my grandfather was usually runs in the
family it's a weird thing yeah but my
dad never drank so interesting yeah he
just doesn't drink at all
that's good man that's good that you you
have that awareness
good friend too to intervene it's just
it's like a weird force that is always
encroaching on you like that i don't
know how else to describe it other than
just like it's always in the back of
your mind that and it can very easily
uh
very easily before you recognize it uh
become
you know something that takes over your
entire personality
there you have it
good for you dude you ever go to aaa or
anything like that no
no i never did uh alcoholics anonymous
but i mean i
from what i understand there's a lot of
like spiritual stuff that you know i
don't really vibe with but it's great i
mean it certainly it clearly helps
people so you know i have a friend who
is in that who's going frequently and it
sounds amazing sounds like a really
incredible yeah the sponsorship concept
is actually what is really helpful
that's what i mean like because i i
did not a but that's basically how i was
able to uh quit drinking was i had a
very close friend who you know
was always by my side we would go out
together we would not drink together he
didn't drink either yeah and and that's
what was incredibly helpful if you're
surrounded if you so if you're trying to
stop an addiction if there's people
around you partaking in that and it will
not make it through yeah and that's
especially if you go back to the problem
uh talking about xqc
if you have a gambling addiction
and you're with a hundred thousand
people that want to watch you and
there's so much rationality going on and
now he's hanging out with train who's
gambling you will not get through that
sponsorship you will not get through
that addiction you will know
no they're you're you're being doubly
enabled you're being enabled because
like you love content and this is the
easiest way to make content that's like
super fun and it is a built-in audience
for it train ranks his community grew by
a massive margin yeah he he wasn't he
wasn't like averaging 38 000 viewers
when he wasn't gambling he was like he
had like 10 000 people watching on good
days and then now he is a
massive massive community um so that's
really bad
uh that's one way to enable it as an
external factor that is like a total
enabler the other is obviously like
they're giving you directly money so you
could continue gambling
and you might even be dumping that money
back into the
bit basically train wreck says he does
this he loses all of his sponsorship
money back to the casino but that's not
good like if you recognize that you
yourself are a [ __ ] addict like why
are you
why are you subjecting other people in
your community to that same addiction
it's incredible
to think that
someone like train wreck
this just should tell you how [ __ ] up
this [ __ ] is
someone like trainwreck is getting
probably two million dollars a month
can come out the end the other side of
this just as broke as the people
uh he's getting into to do the gambling
i mean it could happen to excuse c2
frankly he could lose every [ __ ]
penny he has that [ __ ]
well one one thing that we do know
that steak will keep him afloat until uh
people are no longer watching or until
like gambling is banned in its entirety
from the platform yeah they'll keep him
and and when that goes away when the
stake money runs out like you have a lot
of money right now but you're chasing
that high you're constantly chasing that
high you're constantly chasing the
high of like getting a dub or that
anticipation nothing else feels good
that's one of the other things that
people don't talk about is like when
you're an addict you only want to
[ __ ] you only want to focus on that
addiction it overtakes your entire life
you're constantly chasing that high uh
nothing feels good video games are not
going to feel good nothing else is going
to feel everything else is going to pale
in comparison to that high of like
getting a big win but that anticipation
that is uh being reinforced every time
you hit that [ __ ] slot and you could
no matter how much money you make you
make 10 million dollars a month you
could literally lose all of that [ __ ] uh
with gambling and when the stake money
runs out and and you're [ __ ] dumping
your entire uh life's work into
this this online casino it's not gonna
be great
i would say i had a minor addiction to i
mean minor youtube i was addicted to
this uh painkiller called tramadol
you know about that
no
when i was in it's terrifying
it's it's like a synthetic opioid and
uh well anyway it's a painkiller
and uh back when i was in israel
i was working a desk job for you know
five years and just so bored
and basically my whole time there i was
taking this uh pill
and yeah i was definitely starting to
get addicted to it because like
it's basically all you think about it's
all you want to do
it's all you look forward to
and and then
you
know it starts to affect your
relationships especially with a drug
like that because
when you're
not high on it
uh you're in a horrible mood
and uh
yeah yeah did you feel like you geared
your entire life around like you know
getting your neck yeah yeah getting your
next pill like that's why depending on
what like how much you know financial
comfort you have you
what doesn't change is like your
constant rush that you're seeking the
constant thrill that you're seeking
right because your brain chemistry is
just like being rewired slowly but
surely into
only making you chase that high
um
but
depending on how much financial support
you have you just like it gives you a
runway basically but ultimately it
always ends the same unless you are
unless you get help and stop it yeah i
was able to stop
basically cold turkey when i uh
came back no i stopped before that
it was just getting out of control but i
was taking it like three
uh three times a week and just getting
blasted on the weekends
uh
but yeah it's just it it just ruins your
relationships and it's just so taxing on
everything it's all you want to do
and nothing's going to stop you from
getting the fix and you justify it
you know and
that was just me man it's kind of crazy
to think if i was in a stadium with a
hundred thousand people
and we were all [ __ ] getting high and
trammed all together
yeah what would be the consequence of
that
but there you have it
jor it could be worse you could be
addicting uh to killing innocent people
like george bush that's a comment
yeah it's true he does that is a that is
a
yeah tremendous i just read in the chat
tremolo withdrawal was the [ __ ] worst
man it was horrible but i'm tell i'm
totally clean now i mean
uh
god how did i stop i think i just ran
out of pills one day and i just never
got more
basically
and i was like a month of not being able
to sleep and being super uncomfortable
all the time and just being [ __ ]
miserable and then
you know
i would say i'm totally i would say
for a long long time though for many
years i was just thinking about like man
tramadol would be so fun right now and
all this and this would be so fun on
tram at all but i'm pretty much over it
now i'd say yeah
actually the good thing is the
antidepressants i'm on i can't take [ __ ]
like that because i'll i can get i can
like die
because it's like a serotonin uh
tramadol releases serotonin and if
you're on an ssri
you if you take uh
like serotonin releasing drugs you can
get serotonin syndrome which apparently
is really dangerous
yeah so that's a nice little get uh
control thing for me there you go
so anyway
uh
that was dark we went to a very dark
place uh on this but you know that's why
i don't i don't [ __ ] around with
addiction [ __ ] man well we both have
experiences and yeah that's important
it's really really dangerous [ __ ] but
yeah i think we can see
i i don't know where this is going to go
but it's not going to go anywhere good
for him
i really don't know
unless he just like stops uh and
it doesn't seem like he is he just said
like i mean he was literally doing the
the last uh copium stage of like
debating your own consciousness he
basically said like i would stop if
twitch banned it it's twitch's fault not
much right right and it's like okay well
that well of course you would stuff of
twitch bandit
yeah i know but like that's crazy you
recognize that like you were that level
addicted and like just
put yourself in the shoes of someone who
loves you is all i'm saying put yourself
in the shoes of one of your fans i'm not
doing this [ __ ] virtue signal i don't
give a [ __ ] uh
but put yourself in the shoes of someone
who loves you is in your fan base who is
now also addicted to gambling in a
similar capacity to yourself think about
how it's changed your life think about
how it's changing your personal
relationships and think about what that
would do to like the average juicer it's
not good
you want to talk about jordan peterson
let's do it speaking of uh you know the
outrage speaking of speaking of being
addicted to the pills
oh yeah shout out we have a lot in
common yeah benzo
yeah here's poor jordan he's been racial
off twitter
ratios
get addicted to this ratio jordan yeah
jordan was uh addicted to benzos uh of
course
shout out to my boy there
yeah uh
uh so here he is let's just go down a
whole he had such a crazy such a crazy
week on twitter man
and i love he's pretty much dropped the
facade
of being like i'll just talk to anyone
that will speak to me yeah that's what
he used to say the only reason i'm on
conservative shows is because they're
the only ones that will speak to me
that's not true at all
actually david pakman was like i've
invited you a bunch of times and you
don't respond okay dude if you're not
gonna respond to david pac-man like you
are not trying to be like yeah you are
he's a huge he's one of the biggest
liberal shows no because like david is
like also kind of a lib you know what i
mean he's not like as aggressive as i am
he's very he's very he conducts himself
in a way that's very professional very
professional i respect that about him
i've known him for many years terrible
um if you're not gonna go on david
pac-man's [ __ ] show like you are
literally just like avoiding anything
that is a semblance of the left
he's avoiding anyone with any
critique of him he just wants to be
platformed and again that's why i
removed my podcast with him i know that
you didn't agree with that decision but
i did it because i don't want to
platform him and gateway this [ __ ]
anyway this turned into like a whole
right-wing talking point
uh this this lady i don't actually know
who she is this is you me new oh who is
that um she is a plus size model oh
she's a model okay and um she is on the
as you can see the cover of uh sports
illustrated now i want to say about uh
yumi new
is that
she looks good
i mean no she's very i i think she's
look yeah i think she's very pretty i
said this already she looks she looks
great she looks fine she's very pretty
she is and let's be honest she's not
like that overweight either i mean yeah
i mean this is the this is like oh i
would say a little bit above like
average size for an american yeah it's
not like i mean obviously this ranges
dramatically
but like
do you guys not have like any [ __ ]
women in your lives like i don't
understand like
the people the in cells that like are
like oh she's so fat i'm like it's like
hi honey have you met like have you met
a woman like what the [ __ ] but you know
also i don't know why all the sudden
conservatives act like they've never
heard of a plus size model now like
we've been talking about this [ __ ] for
like decades
and then all of a sudden
this girl gets on the cover and turns
into like this whole cultural war issue
uh jordan pearson tweeted out this one
blew my tits man when i read this i'll
can i can i do this can i do the voice
oh yeah please do please sorry not
beautiful
and no amount of authoritarian tolerance
is going to change that what what a
toxic how dare society tell overweight
women they're beautiful it's disgusting
yes
totalitarian
it's the dragon of chaos
saying that
this [ __ ] needs to know her place no
he's like
he's literally like you will not force
me to crank a hot load
to this lady no matter what she is just
not my type i am not doing it
i am not i tried i tried and tried i
tried jerking off over and over again to
the cover model of sports illustrated
swimsuit 2022.
and i could not rub one out
hand me my pencils i'm getting stressed
he's just
i it's just very funny to like try to
intellectualize uh just basically saying
a woman is mid you know what i mean like
he's just he's trying like
no matter authoritarian tolerance first
of all beauty standards are entirely
good beauty is subjective this is beauty
subjective and i know
tons of people
who would consider this like that's my
ideal like this is yeah thick ladies
this is the thick lady summer okay a lot
of people find that to be like that's my
ideal i'm calling it it's a it's a thick
lady summer okay
uh and it's also muscle muscle girl
summer okay straight up okay muscle
girls like non non like uh you know
western standard beauty standards i'm
sorry hassan are coming back but if i
see muscles on a woman
my dick shrinking
i do not want a woman that can out bench
press me it's ridiculous men have it
hard enough we can't have women walking
around stronger that's outrageous it's
all we have
but yeah beauty standards are not only
entirely uh entirely subjective changes
throughout culture change throughout
history um you can go uh you can go back
in time and and look at you know what
people consider to be like fertile or
figures of fertility and you will find
that like you may know that yeah you
mean you fits the the these probably
throughout the history of humanity she
is probably
the exact
idea of like the beautiful woman yes and
this doesn't mean that like you have to
find her currently and presently attract
no okay you don't jordan no trust me you
don't have to [ __ ] her and i'm sure the
invitation's not there either so don't
worry about it so nobody's for i love
the author the authoritarians are
forcing me to beat off to this yeah
don't have to find her attractive nobody
[ __ ] but the craziest thing about this
to me
is jordan peterson is a therapist by by
profession yeah i mean he's my
profession this man is a therapist and
he's tweeting out [ __ ] fat chicks yeah
but but like he's doing it in a you know
brilliant objective and intellectually
honest way though obviously and his like
fan base of [ __ ] weirdo in cells or
like yeah you're right you just owned
epic ownage jordan peterson a thera a
tor author authoritarian tolerance no
you don't have to buy the magazine dude
you have to look at it it's it's really
funny to just like come out of the gate
swinging and being like i could not jerk
off to this and that's unacceptable it's
just this is probably the most
outrageous tweet he said a lot of dumb
[ __ ] one of my favorite ones of recent
was just you know uh
trudeau made conversion therapy uh
illegal and he called it moral
grandstanding that's one of my yeah and
favorites but anyway he went on to have
a full
on look at that look at the likes on
that 52 000
interesting
oh we have his ratio in here right i uh
yeah we do i basically i basically wrote
that exact same thing but just like
posted a photo of him looking like [ __ ]
for those of you who haven't seen it
like
so let me here i'll give you i'll show
the ratio before we move on just for
also before we move on just weird twist
i just pulled up her uh wikipedia
article
uh
relatives uncle
steve aoki what the [ __ ] interesting oh
that's uh superman such a weird crap
[Laughter]
wait is he a problem i did i don't know
i mean he's everywhere wasn't his dad
like literally homies with jordan
belfort well yeah his ad was rocky
and founded
i believe yeah i want to ask you a
question don't be mad who the [ __ ] is
that
like stevie i don't know who the f i've
seen
uh famous for uh his song with the
bloody beetroots uh
yeah he's he's a dj he's a [ __ ]
stupid dj he's like an old school dj
from series says here's active like
since 1996. he does like a bunch of
vegas residencies and children okay
player let's get the rules
he has his hands in everything
you can't escape him we go with the
round table and the beatbox
i turn into bill cosby yeah what the
[ __ ] was that like boomer [ __ ] i don't
know what's going on anyway but yeah so
here's your response you absolutely
brutally [ __ ] up
racial and actually what that tweet was
so outrageous was kind of nice to see
that not only you actually maybe you can
send me a link so i can look but there
was a lot of mainstream people who don't
usually get involved in politics yeah
dunking on him in the comments no
because this is like this is silly
you're a silly [ __ ] like you're
literally [ __ ] no it's great he
exposed himself
he went full conservative and you can't
go full conservative well he's been
doing that he's been doing that and this
is just he's pandering
i think what happened
was he saw this being coming a culture
issue with people like ben shapiro and
stuff who just released a whole video
about it right there you want to know
why and he saw that and he's like oh
this is the top people so i'm going in
and then he caught [ __ ] i don't know why
everyone got so mad
go ahead because people love thick
ladies okay
people
love thick ladies
that's what it is it's thick lady summer
why'd they calling it one more time okay
wait straight up there were people that
are his fans that were like my
girlfriend that
he's like calm down jordan no those were
my favorite ones yeah
like
so wait hold on
you know quite frankly hassan i'm i'm
really more attracted to you
than the model
um
oh yeah this is one of his thing this is
one of his saying reject modernity
embrace tradition yeah
like all right let's go back and see
what
perfect
beauty look i mean yeah exactly exactly
that's a figure of fertility like
straight up like the the ultimate uh
female physique at a certain time
um you know who's perfect is a hassan i
really really enjoy his sport and chill
that hassan [ __ ] he's so masculine oh
he's got a throbber in his pants i
always
whenever i see ethan klein i say to
myself i'm gonna hamona
i don't like
women but that ethan klein he's got a
dump truck yeah my jaw drops to the
floor my tongue rolls out like the red
carpet hassan what what kind of
underwear do you wear do you got a
thor's hammer in your pants
my good friend
where would we be without men
i just really love his physique can i
tuck can i touch your biceps uh where
would we be without hassan's biceps
it's just it's ridiculous and uh but so
people started talking about him and
then he did
so yeah so the next one after everybody
jumped on him through it instead of
remember this guy's a therapist right
he goes he does tours preaching about
how to
better yourself so instead of
reflecting on like even his own fans
being like jordan my wife looks like
this and i think she's beautiful so
maybe tone it down yeah no
self-reflection he says rage away
panderers
and tell me you believe that such images
are not conscious and cynical
manipulations by the oh so virtuous
politically correct
he's acting like she's a mutant like oh
yeah he really is acting like he's just
absolutely the average looking like
woman yeah pretty like like she like it
was a blob of flesh and teeth and hair
coming out it's like jordan literally
looks like [ __ ] like he actually looks
like a you know hairy dish rag and he's
over here [ __ ] talking about how
other people look and how people should
look now the irony of that by the way
the authoritarian uh the the
authoritarian thing that he's talking
about is like he believes that beauty is
objective which is psychotic uh if you
dive deeper into like art and culture
and beauty being subjective you arrive
at another group of individuals who used
to think that of course nazis they also
have
no no but that's that's it that's the
truth conservatives are aligned
universally with a lot of fascist
ideology fascist but i've spent my life
studying nazis bucko how dare you no i'm
not saying jordan peterson is one
[Laughter]
how hold on zach play the keemstar sound
like
i think it's pretty rich of you to be
talking about
death to all jews
what
that's keemstar he said tell everyone to
go type death told jews to ethanol jesus
christ now the other one about the no he
hates the jews no no the one about
hassan the one about hassan he's going
to say you you want to see black people
in the downfall i think that's what
hassan wants bad stuff to happen to
black people it's called rich of you to
grandstand yeah called out no i'm not
saying jordan peters is a nazi okay but
he does he does uh you know he does do a
lot of red pilling uh maybe
inadvertently but
don't the main point the main takeaway
in this situation is like if you are
authoritarian about like uh subjecting
people to beauty standards and you
recognize that beauty standards can then
you recognize the beauty standards can
change by what you are seeing in the
news cycle so jordan peterson basically
is saying i want my authoritarian beauty
standards to maintain like i want i only
want to see women well that are size
zero
size zero i want to make sure that women
are invisible when they turn to the side
like paper thin
they look like my daughter michaela
mckayla's [ __ ] jacked too so my
daughter michaela she eats only meat
yeah she's a perfect woman
have you seen her knockers oh boy i mean
i i do love me i'm her dad but man oh
man i'll tell you if we weren't related
i'd love to take her for a round of
applause
when she's not actively trying to kill
her father uh i would say that uh you
know
by by giving her uh a covet from a uh
that she got from a a serbian uh no who
could i got it from arsenal no traveling
with no she she had just previously been
dating copper tape but then it was the
next guy that hassan's talking about and
i can't believe that
jordan peterson connection that's the
yes i can believe it it's perfect i mean
they're both they're both alpha men that
are just teaching people uh human
trafficking how to yeah how to
uh
so jordan continues i have recently
stopped accessing twitter for three
weeks as an experiment i had some of my
staff post videos links etc
uh i'm sure i'm glad he has a staff to
maintain his twitter account it was a
genuine relief i started to read and
write more i started using again a few
days ago and i would say that my life
got worse again almost instantly
the fl the endless flood of vicious
insults is really not something that can
be experienced anywhere else i like to
follow the people i know but i think the
incentive structure of the platform
makes it intingely
intrinsically dangerous and insane
so i told my staff to change my password
to keep me from the temptation and i am
departing once again he's not if i have
something to say i'll write an article
or make a video if the issue is not
important enough to justify that then
perhaps it would be best to let it go
so so he's posting five minutes after
this he posted literally 20 times yeah i
i counted yeah he's 28 i think by the
time 28 times by the next morning yeah
he just goes on to talk about some
[ __ ] too yeah so the thing is like
look at this twitter is a platform now
uh don't get mad at me disability
activists but twitter is a platform
where whoever is the most mentally ill
is making the best posts okay sorry it's
just the truth okay okay and and
i as a victim of uh many cyber bullying
attempts and
can say that like yeah it feels terrible
when you are in the crosses when you're
the main guy for the day and everyone's
just like piling on you and telling you
that you should uh kill yourself um it's
not great but also it does feel so sweet
when you're not on the receiving end of
it like i just i totally understand why
people do it there's definitely
shot and friday of course i totally
understand why people like it especially
when it's like valid especially when
it's uh against someone who's like
legitimately is just like being a
[ __ ] buffoon or
outright evil in that situation it just
oh well here's one of the top comments
for one of his fans
she started big fan here i find my
girlfriend with the body like this quite
beautiful dial it back homie and then
he's like and then his response to his
fan being a little bit upset yeah just
keep pandering losers yeah this [ __ ] is
fat
yeah you're what your girlfriend is
thick and i do not like it i do not like
your wife you need to find a skinnier
girl bucko
i'm a huge fan of yours and always
getting my young adult son and daughters
to watch your videos i've even gifted
your self offered self self authoring
course but i have to disagree beauty is
subjective you can be older heavier and
still be beautiful is it the beauty
standard no
i remember when i used to watch your
lectures on theology
uh it was utterly fascinating and i
listened to all your podcasts and
getting your life straight and believing
in yourself it was so inspiring
comforting where does the sudden
aggression of hatred come from
that's your brain on right-wing politics
yeah he's saying
again
thick mommies were far too powerful
and and were finally able to take down
the the giant
the the giant of like red pilling so
many people well
he really he bro that tweet was so it's
two two two things have been able to
destroy jordan peterson so far uh i'm
not even gonna say like make a joke
about benzo addiction it's actually a
dumpster diving raccoon by the name of
slavojek who absolutely comes through
him and then and and think mommies when
he did the debate they debated and he
destroyed him you've never seen the
slavoj jordan peterson debate oh my god
you're very famous when it goes where
yes are the marxists what is it really
good that's pretty good
i mean i love i love it's
because you know how he uh always taught
i mean he even talked about it when he
came on our show all those years ago
about uh the uh post-modern neo-marxists
being the main enemy of uh progress in
sustainability no i know that that just
jordan's there my mind so the guy who he
debated debated him just on the topic of
communism right like it was just kind of
like an or marxism
he debated on a bunch of different
topics where basically slavo who has
written like seven million books right
he literally just like never shuts the
[ __ ] up he's only writing books about
philosophy about marxism stalinism all
that stuff yeah um
he he uh
he he destroyed jordan peterson with
like in this one simple trick which was
asking where these marxists are wait
when did this take place it was a couple
years about like two three years ago you
think it set him back i think that
literally spiraled uh that was the first
time he got like adequate pushback from
someone that was also like kind of you
know gross and slimy looking i love him
by the way he we i mean we call that
raccoon out of love yeah um
that like it wasn't like a woman right
so his audience was like wait a minute
that guy that kind of looks like what i
could look like is like owning this dude
effectively oh wow interesting maybe
pull that off he basically revealed that
he's only read like not even fully read
the communist manifesto which i think is
pretty funny because it's like a [ __ ]
pamphlet dog like that's that's that's
the extent of his knowledge on on
marxism and come on oh
are you you don't find that moment for
me i think his son or uh maybe just got
it yeah oh hell yeah let's see this
i'm actually really excited to watch
this
only three hundred thousand views though
we got no no there's so much more this
was like at the time
of it yeah yeah yeah okay
let's see think they are really where
did you find these data i don't
or what you are fighting against as
sometimes you call it uh
postmodern neo-marxism i know what you
mean
all this from political correctness to
these excesses of whatever
uh spirit of envy and so on and so on
and so on and so on do you think they
are really where did you find this data
i don't know them i would ask you here
give me some names or whatever where are
the marxists here i don't know any i
don't
who who is the mark
this is so satisfying because he [ __ ]
won't shut up about this pokes yeah his
[ __ ] yeah he uses it as the spectre
this boogie goes like describing every
[ __ ] thing it's pretty funny because
like college uh in and of itself in in
you know bourgeois capitalist nations
like the united states of america is an
institution that reinforces the dominant
neoliberal hegemonic attitude yes they
are socially in many instances a lot of
the well-educated people in college
campuses are socially progressive to a
certain degree but the idea that like
you know college campuses are dominating
no mark marx this is [ __ ] insane like
there is no marxist movie if you've ever
taken an econ course if you've ever
taken an econ course in any american
institution econ 1010102 is
basically completely shut off gated from
any kind of marxian uh marxian economics
the the furthest i guess left you can go
is keynesian economics it's still
neoclassical uh and capitalist economics
that is like the furthest uh the
furthest like supposedly the closest you
can get to marxism which it's not even
marxism it's entirely different than
that so um let's see what jordan says
yeah let's see if he has a response here
jordan's like he's in his oh [ __ ]
posture too he's all this guy's look at
the butt dude alpha posture alpha
posture beta posture
red pilled
it just also looks like he was
frivolously googling on his computer oh
he's in front of his laptop okay
i think they they feel like a good
vampire fierce garlic
this is why they are already the one who
is not a marxist but at least approaches
economic topic bernie sanders he's
already under attack as white male and
all that stuff and so on i simply i
simply
my problem would be this one what do you
describe as
post-modern neo-marxism
where is really the marxist element in
it they are for equality story where
they are for equality these cultural
struggles proper names how do we call
each other do you see in them in
political correctness and so on any
genuine will of to change society i
don't see i think it's a
hypermoralization
hypermoralization
silent admission of a defeat let's see
it yeah dude wait wait pause for a
second though because he's he's spitting
right now okay so listen no the reason
why i say this is because like obviously
i mean he is a
young hegelian uh but he he uh he
himself has a as a world view that is
also
what i would consider like mainstream
liberal attitudes would consider zizek
to also be like an anti-sjw to a certain
respect
and and he recognizes that a lot of
these like cultural movements a lot of
these social movements are not actually
revol they don't actually revolve around
changing the underlying material
realities of the marginalized people it
supposedly speaks for um and is simply
just like a distraction or rather in
many respects just like uh a a
a way to like feel a little bit better
about yourself by like trying to
redefine or sanitize culture it's it's
ultimately powerless so that's what
that's the reason why he's like able to
own him because he can correctly
uh
he can correctly
expose the underlying the the underlying
attitude the underlying fear that we all
have the fear of powerlessness in the
face of structural change and why we
engage in like acts of uh i don't know
witch hunting or whatever the [ __ ] on or
like getting your favorite tv show to
change like uh the cast or something
it's it's [ __ ]
let's see what jordan has to say give me
no it's again it's not a rhetorical
question or politely saying you are an
idiot you don't know what you're talking
about
you're out you're being outclassed
intellectually bro
you look like an ant right now when you
attack somebody you said aggressively
and what suit read more tell me whom so
i'm asking you now not read more i don't
advise you but who are give me some
names and so on and who are these most
modern egalitarian neo-marxists and
where do you see any kind even of
marxism i see in it mostly and an
impotent and utterly impotent
moralization
[Applause]
please i'm so sorry that there was no no
that's that's no problem well i mean
um organization like look at his hands
this shaking beta ass yeah no he's he's
getting on wait i want to see what he
says
in heights um
what's it called
heterodox academy and other
organizations like that have documented
an absolute dearth of conservative
voices in the social sciences and the
humanities and about 25 according to the
what i think are reliable surveys
approximately 25 of social scientists in
the us identify themselves as marxists
and so there's that
if your entire argument revolves around
like well 25 of college professors uh
identify self-identify as marx is like
yeah dude 25
like even then you're like [ __ ]
losing your mind making it seem like
this is a it's literally all he talks
about is neil marx yeah like he will not
shut the [ __ ] up but i want to see this
i want to see this well yeah your
questions seem to me to focus more on
the
peculiar relationship that i've noticed
and that people have disputed between
post-modernism and and neo-marxism and i
see the connection between
the postmodernist types and the marxists
as a sleight of hand that replaced the
notion of the oppression of the
proletariat by the bourgeoisie as the
oppression by one identity group by
another totally angry okay so but that
but so now look oh what do you say
he's saying that no what did he say
literally this guy and i'm gonna
describe it to you no but i just want to
know literally what he said
he said that he he's doing the same
thing that like conceptual james does
basically saying that no no
the words he said
what are you asking me okay wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait he
said something i just want i didn't hear
because people were cheering here i got
autograph caption on all right one
identity group by another totally angry
okay so that what did he say is it
totally agree with you oh oh okay shakes
i totally agree with you okay but what
he's basically describing is that like
they took marx's theory
uh and and the underlying like the the
the the
class element removed the class element
from marx's theory and now use it for
like other kinds of like critical
uh critical race theory for example this
is actually um a little bit ahead of the
curve on like what the republican party
does now with like critical race here
they basically say this exact same thing
still to this day where they're saying
like oh it's actually marxist and bad
but uh they are substituting like uh the
the oppression of the proletariat in the
working class by the capital-owning
bourgeois class to the oppression of one
identity uh against another it's it's a
it's it's misattributed it's false but
ultimately
it kind of is a self-defeating point
which is that they're not marxist
so you're wrong
that's why slavo says i agree with you
because they're not marketed
let's see but that but so now look
we could
see i guess that's where we might have a
dispute because i think what happened
especially in france in the 1960s is as
the as the radical
marxist post-modern types like darada
and foucault realized that they were
losing the moral battle especially after
the information
came out of the soviet union in the
manner that it came out that
that the whole bloody stelliness
yeah
the whole stalinist catastrophe along
with the entire maoist catastrophe that
they didn't really have a leg to stand
on and instead of revising fundamentally
human history and this is a marxist
notion should be regarded as uh the
eternal class struggle between the
economically deprived and the oppressors
they just recast it and said well it's
not based on economics it's based on
identity but it's still fundamentally
oppressor against oppressed and to me
that meant that they smuggled the
the the fundamental narrative of marxism
and many of its goals back into the
argument without ever admitting that
they did so now i've been criticized you
know for this supposition because
people who are post-modernist say look
one of the hallmarks of post-modernism
is skepticism of meta-narratives it's
like i know that perfectly well and i
also know that marxism is a
meta-narrative and so you shouldn't be
able to be able to peterson also
skeptical of metanarratives but i still
see the union of those two things in the
insistence that the best the appropriate
way to look at the view world is just a
battleground between all right shut up
jordan um i mean it's it's it
he describes the inherent contradiction
uh between marxism and poetry well
basically it has nothing to do with
marxism yeah but
that's it they just because they're
relying on uh a century of red scare
propaganda to to just basically say well
that's socialist that's marxism anyone
who cares about social issues is a
communist
which i mean i don't have a problem with
that yet go ahead it's true okay shout
out to the king zizik
zizik hassan no comment pervert's guide
to ideology is uh something that you
could watch uh
quickly and easily
one of his uh one of his uh
documentaries one of his movies called
pervert's guide to ideology you're not
gonna comment on that i mean he just
looks great i don't know what to say
he's driving you to acknowledge what was
on the
is
screen
also from um jija comes from a long line
of uh like you know
unkempt and disheveled philosophers with
uh sexy girlfriends oh really does he
have a slamming girlfriend he is a
beautiful wife pull that up pull that up
because i mean he's got intellectual
there you go red pills eat your heart
out he's the [ __ ] enemy of all red
pills
they think that they have to be a
perfect um
male specimen and zizzix pulling it
okay oh my god what's up player oh yeah
beautiful yeah and look at him man that
guy is a [ __ ] the lion the slovenian
lion
[Applause]
oh wow ma'am
kind of suave though back in the day you
kind of looked like a
what was that french actor that all the
all the soccer moms love back in the day
oh
pardon uh luke uh no not look bassant
but he's in luke busan
gerard depardieu yeah yeah yeah yeah
every friendship yeah
hey i got a question for you
tim poole
what happens if a woman is on the way to
get an abortion at eight months but goes
into labor in the lobby of the abortion
clinic and accidentally delivers the
baby before it could be terminated hell
yeah obviously you kill the bait you
throw the baby in the incinerator yeah
well that has happened that's what
happened they literally they actually
did uh
um not terminate the baby in that
situation that has happened one time i
believe but like
again
the these these not in eight months
though
um no i mean it happens premature uh
premature births are
a common occurrence for sure but but
people don't get abortions at eight
months unless it's like life-threatening
right exactly that's precisely what i
was going to say in most circumstances
and this is a really disgusting thing
that conservatives do is like 93 93 of
abortions are happening in the first
trimester okay 93 percent six percent of
abortions happen in the second trimester
oftentimes because like people don't
know that they're pregnant as a
consequence of not being able to get
adequate reproductive health care
services so thank you republicans for
that
um and only one percent of terminations
only one percent of abortions happen in
the third trimester
now
uh that is an incredibly low percentage
obviously in the grand scheme of things
but that's all these [ __ ] dingus talk
about they can't shut the [ __ ] up about
third trimester abortions because
they're like basically trying to say
like if he just has viability outside
the body and they're trying to liken
abortion to a murder as best as possible
they're trying to liken a fetus into a
baby as best as possible that's why they
use this argument now
what's really horrifying about this is
as you correctly pointed out third third
trimester abortions in nearly every
single one
uh is is done through medical
consultation and it's done to women that
wanted to carry that pregnancy the term
no one is [ __ ] carrying a baby inside
of them for eight [ __ ] months a fetus
inside of them for eight months until it
turns out addictive that would be to get
yes you have to get rid of your nearly
born child that's just that yes
traumatic man so that's precisely why i
think it's disgusting because they're
like shamelessly using that
as as like the main hypothetical the
main example and it's it's just really
[ __ ] stupid yeah the supposition the
the supposition that there's women out
there
who are just willing to
ch they're like you know what at eight
months i don't want this baby take it
out and kill it
nobody does that and
it's kind of a self-report on you really
think women are out there that evil bro
and nobody does that and isn't it
illegal to do that at eight months i
don't think you can legally um with the
baby then i i think it it differs uh
state by state some states offer full
autonomy to the to the carrier which is
you know an understandable legal
boundary to set specifically because
you don't want to stop
the actual women that need to get this
uh you know that need to get this
termination done this abortion done for
medical reasons because you know you
want to like
like what
doctors are not in the business of like
forcing women to carry pregnancies to
term and and have them die as a
consequence of that even when there's no
viability when i say illegal i mean you
know with i'm just saying with not like
an elective surgery to be like i don't
want the baby it's eight months yeah um
in that situation i think like they can
um i mean like i said it differs uh
state by state uh and but in most in can
you get it eighth month abortion in any
state just elective
no uh
most states do not without like a
medical emergency i don't believe so
yeah yeah
like is that medical consultation that's
a fallacy
that they say you can just willy-nilly
the one of the talking was like you can
go get a
abortion the day before you give birth
or they say they always use uh ralph
northam uh famously uh
a doctor who uh
either did blackface or wore kkk robes
we still don't know to this day which
one he was uh governor of virginia back
in the day democrat uh he was on a he
was on a talk show where he was
basically talking about the medical
procedure of the incredibly rare process
in which like you have a stillbirth
uh you have a stillbirth uh like forced
induced
pregnancy where they like where they uh
have to you know basically terminate
um
uh terminate the child even after the
birth has like taken place like a forced
birth has taken place and it's a brutal
medical process right it's it's
horrifying
but you know what else is horrifying
open heart surgery dumbass so if you
know someone is like describing someone
a medical professional is describing
open heart surgery you're gonna be like
oh that's that's gross let's not do that
yeah obviously when you have people
describe medical procedures um
it's going to sound
uh especially in your luddite mind it's
going to sound gross and scary okay but
that's what this is it is a medical
procedure this intervention
uh is a necessity
uh even in the super extreme like once
in a lifetime example that uh northern
was using that is like misattributed and
and bastardized where they say like you
know democrats want to kill babies after
they're born
um is done to to
like serious terminally ill
serious terminal illness to the fetus
like that won't survive the
post uh post birth like will not survive
for like more than [ __ ] three weeks
yeah you know what i mean and it's an
incredibly traumatic process so this is
a wanted pregnancy i've seen graphs of
that where they're like
it looks horrific and it's scary as hell
uh where they like go in and they have
to like cut the baby and take pieces out
of it and [ __ ] and like remove it piece
by piece
uh but that's not what every abortion is
yeah um they it's so gross they try to
make it like i watch that youtuber
family
uh
the
they're [ __ ] disgusting yeah i mean
that that lady should stop but you know
but i don't know about the family but
they faked their kid having cancer for
views did you yeah i do [ __ ] more
power to them on that front but like
they should stop having children oh my
gosh she has like 11 children dude what
are you doing do they really
it is certain maybe i'm thinking of
different people they have a lot of no
no the blonde they have i'm i'm joking
i'm exaggerating but i think she's like
like two
i thought i have like six the lebrance
how many children do the lebranches oh
no they have they have a they've got
three kids and one fourth on the way and
the fourth on the way yeah you gotta
stop
stop it it's not pringles lady
you know you can you can stop yourself
they do look like a can of pringles
though don't they i mean it's just wild
to me that like you know like if you
want if you want to have as many
children as possible because they're
like little content they're related they
love that multiplying [ __ ] yeah
and it's also great content for them
like she has an addiction she has a
breeding kink watch this yeah for sure
yeah more power to you but like also
stop please you have you've had too many
children
uh we only have like 10 minutes left
so we're like five
to be hitting on the elon thing we can
talk about it just to hit it because
it's in the title
uh where do we start with elon um he
obviously is backing out of the twitter
deal like we all predicted from the very
beginning
i have to say i'm impressed
that he was able to get out of the deal
without pissing people off he made it
all twitter's fault
which was a stroke of genius i have to
say
he basically was like twitter's been
lying about how many bots there are and
therefore i'm
putting the deal on hold he's not going
to do it it's a [ __ ] it's the dumbest
thing ever to buy for him to buy twitter
so there is a there is two different uh
schools of thought here like one first
of all there's a termination fee you
can't just billion dollar publicly
that's nothing who cares ah that's a
it's a big that's a good amount of money
there's a good amount of free money for
twitter i think he
in my opinion no it's great for twitter
yeah but for elon
i mean we theorized that from the
beginning he expected just to
part with that money
for whatever
coverage and [ __ ] he's been getting
uh
i think the reason why it came out
okay one thing i'll say about the
twitter thing is that like it was an
incredibly like
mind-bogglingly stupid uh thing to try
and do yeah um and i think he was doing
it for like uh short-term marketing
benefits potentially yeah but he does
use twitter as a as a way to boost his
stock prices is is uh tesla texas stock
is like incredibly overvalued regardless
right and it slated to continue
uh being that way because it's treated
as a tech company so it has like this
major multiplier um and he uses twitter
a lot to to change the dynamic or to
like become newsworthy or to even like
reveal his like new inventions that he's
never gonna actually follow through on
um
so i think that's why he wanted to
control and potentially manipulate uh
public opinion and and you know it was
worth the bills for him the coverage he
got the good the goodwill amongst
conservatives
he got he probably made over a billion
dollars from all those i mean who knows
[ __ ] he was able to promote well i think
he like had to sell some of his stocks
to be able to put like oh you know what
there's no down and then also what a
good another theory is that
he used
so he sold tesla stocks
so he could buy twitter yeah
but it's possible
that
you know he never intended to buy
twitter and he wanted to take a bunch of
money out of tesla without panicking
people so he paid a little bit billion
dollar taxes
that's believable i think you know
um anyway but like so he he could have
known what the percentage of bots uh was
right i mean that was that was literally
in the contract but he waved it and um
and now he's making a big fuss about it
but he's violated that contract with the
non-disparagement clause like numerous
times already like including i think
like putting a poop emoji under the
reply as like a [ __ ] current ceo
which is such a weird concept to like
go through in arbitration you know what
i mean like you're gonna have to like a
lawyer is gonna be like well your honor
the poop emoji in this circumstance was
very clearly like a negative thing to
say
um
and
and and um the other reason why he might
be making a big stink about the bots is
so that he can
uh he gets out and he's not the bad guy
shave like a couple billion
well he he might try to shave a couple
billion off the off the well price
because the original price that he gave
the stock has gone down significantly
since he made that offer both his and
twitter's yeah now the
stock market has but the original but
the original price he was uh the
original price he was pointing to was
like already super high right the
original price he was pointing to was
insane it was way above yeah um and
that's what made it uh
fall within the fiduciary responsibility
of the board to like actually take
seriously if he had come in with like a
lower a lower price point for the stock
they could have had a better argument to
say like no we don't want elon musk to
take control we don't want him to like
buy uh out the company but
the number he gave was really high so
this is one way to like access that
barrier and now that the deal is uh is
is slated to be completed now he can
like actually force uh forced to drive
the price down and then you know
buy it 10 billion dollars cheaper you
know what i mean well potentially
yeah i mean he's in a tough spot tesla
is down 30 this month twitter's down 17
percent
but what was his initial offer was like
was really high uh it was like 56
dollars yeah now it's 38 that's a huge
difference man yeah
it was in that ballpark in the 50s
something well anyway he's he announced
in the past i voted democrat because
they were the party of kindness so
stupid but now they are the party of
division and hate so i can no longer
support them by the way this is coming
literally after the the buffalo shooter
did uh i know gross white supremacist
terror attacks and i will be promoting
he was literally just repeating like
great replacement theory [ __ ] that you
hear on from tucker carlson every
[ __ ] night no that's great and like
actual republicans all the time no it's
great um
just because just because liberals hate
you elon cause you're a [ __ ] like
anti-union basically uh slave driver
uh doesn't mean they're the party of
hate that's the funniest part about this
is that like biden famously said to in a
closed-door meeting to billionaires and
millionaires and nothing would
fundamentally change and he was right
about that nothing fundamentally has
changed but even the minor support that
joe biden has shown to like chris smalls
shouts out the chris smalls of amazon
labor union by having by inviting him to
the white house is enough for
billionaires to [ __ ] panic because
they're such little babies dude like
they literally run society i saw a clip
of i don't know if you have this in here
of elon was like uh democrats are too
pro union joe biden has completely lost
the plot because uh he's just slave to
the unions yeah
like democrats couldn't even push for a
15 minimum wage at the federal level and
like use the [ __ ] procedural hurdles
like the senate parliamentarian to be
like oh i guess our hands are tied we
can't do anything meanwhile these guys
are [ __ ] freaking out just because
joe biden says like labor unions are
good
i mean
he announced now watch the dirty trick
campaign against me unfold he goes on
says political attacks on me will
escalate dramatically in the coming
months you know what that is right no
[ __ ] dumbass
i think a sec investigation is underway
i've heard that i've read that
i'm just saying oh this is the perfect
way to get ahead of it i'm just saying
he's following trump's playbook it's
pretty incredible just saying
he can't like what's he the the sec is a
feckless and and toothless institution
for the most part but uh more power to
them i really do hope they they get his
ass well
howard uh responds when you are
explicitly political you should expect
people to treat you as such what part of
that is confusing to you i'm not
surprised at all that was to inoculate
the public as a prominent vaccine
advocate almost using that like an
insult right
you should understand that yale is the
epicenter of woke mind virus attempting
to destroy civilization like holy [ __ ]
when i when i think about like it isn't
my virus
like legacy college like old money like
100 percent exactly what i was going to
say
when i think about the epicenter of evil
in this country when i think about the
the epicenter of woke mind viruses
attempting to destroy civilization i
think of the talent farm to the cia like
this is literally like yale is famous
for notorious like harvard yeah we're
having some of the absolute worst pieces
of [ __ ] like evil
yeah is he a yale alumni yep hell yeah
there you see golden bones baby yeah
yeah yellow is like they produce these
american psycho people and they're like
yeah they're this is an institution that
is that's why they exist prominently
and and very successfully
uh
indoctrinating people into the the
neo-liberal capitalist bloodthirsty
pro-american imperialist ideology
on a daily [ __ ] basis but because
elon musk doesn't even think about those
sorts of things he only thinks about it
from like oh are they saying like
are they pro gay well there's the epic
woke mind virus
i i think like the elon's posting at
this point
is like lol pepe memes own the living at
this point like it's so embarrassing
it's really cringe uh he's like a child
and he's basically just posting paypay
memes at this point
but his fan base loves it they eat it up
look at that
seven thousand likes dude conservatives
[ __ ] love it but i'll tell you what i
don't think conservatives buy teslas
even
loving to even loving i mean i don't
know it doesn't you don't really need to
sell tesla's to be able to you know
drive up the tesla stock price that's
what i was kind of saying originally if
that was the case listen
i'm you know i
i have teslas i've had teslas i just
pre-ordered the bmw new electric coming
out
uh and i'm not going to be driving
teslas anymore and once there's
competition i think a lot of people who
have supported tesla's for the ev and
the social movement of it are going to
be having wandering eyes at the vehicles
coming out i personally don't think it's
like you're you're doing like this i
don't believe in like uh you know
adequate consumption consumption choices
like as a viable substitution for like
labor organizing
but having said that i think that
tesla's are just dog [ __ ] in general i
do like my i like my electric vehicle my
take can more than i like the tesla's
that's for sure
someone who's driven by i'm very excited
to get a different electric vehicle so i
think once more competition comes out
uh tesla's gonna [ __ ]
well it will destroy it will destroy uh
one of the main uh sources of revenue
for elon musk for many many years is the
um the credit swaps like that they
engage in like there's a there's a eevee
there's a carbon credit that
um
that elon musk like tesla has been using
by basically selling uh the allocation
that like other other companies are
supposed to have with like ev and like
lowering the carbon footprint okay that
tesla has that has basically funded
tesla for a very long time like way more
than the actual uh cars itself um
here i'll i'll i'll pull it up actually
we're edit we're basically at a time
yeah
i want to watch this clip because it
just shows what a piece of [ __ ] he is
uh it's only one minute long this guy's
a [ __ ] and by the way tesla has beat
uh first quarter income expectations
with more than double the previous
quarter's carbon credit sales so that's
still like a main driver of revenue for
him
is another government subsidy basically
of all the other ev startups which one
has impressed you the most
well i think the company making the most
progress besides tesla is actually bw
which is not a startup but it could be
viewed in some ways as a startup from an
electric vehicle standpoint so vw is
doing the most
on the electric vehicle front
um
i think there will be some very strong
companies uh coming out of china
um
there's just a lot of
super talented hard-working people in
china that are
strongly believe in in manufacturing and
and they will
figure they'll they won't just be
burning the midnight oil they'll be
burning the three am oil
so
um they won't even leave the leave the
factory type of thing whereas in america
people are trying to avoid going to work
at all
move the chinese what an insane [ __ ]
first of all i mean shouts out that
shouts out to elon musk for america
solidarity solidarity with the chinese
comedy's party okay i'm glad he just
said it though he's like listen i expect
my workers to work
22 hours a day
yeah i mean listen listen i'm all i'm
saying and not complaining
and you know maybe maybe not so bad okay
you know like dude
get a [ __ ] grip man it's crazy that
you think it's okay to just come out and
say that like holy [ __ ] bro also you
can't be pro china while simultaneously
[ __ ] being like oh let's make uh
boring tunnels instead of [ __ ]
high-speed rail because that that is one
really good thing that the chinese
government has done okay
we're caring about his projects let's be
honest
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about free speech
what that's what he says he wants to buy
twitter
no billionaire has ever cared about free
speech dude it's like such a dumb thing
that like it's just a way to farm idiots
to be like
those care about free speech because
they think like free speech is like
saying hate speech with no consequences
yeah it just means they want to say the
n word yeah that's basically all that
yeah the guy who like [ __ ] shut down
unions and the guy who like was
effectively sued by
uh by the with the government for for uh
the
horrifying uh racial conditions like
racial discrimination that occurred in
his factories is is pro free speech all
right we gotta go
hassan has somewhere to be
yep thank you guys for watching
the leftovers
from our underground compound
shielded and lead
um
we have uh nuclear bunker doors
we are ready for the fallout and nothing
will ever shut us up
ever
thank you for watching
stay strong powerful beautiful people
hell yeah hell yeah brother
see you tomorrow
friday after diet
it's friday baby all right take care
guys
[Music]
you